hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round five of this year's
Granite Granite chenai Grand Masters
tournament featuring s andov and GES and
sarov has been featured on the channel
quite a lot uh he's a two times world
champion he won the under 10 world
championship and under 14 the world
championship and he's also a three times
European Champion uh but his most
notable game however is the one where he
defeated Magnus Carlson in the 2010
Olympiad in Hy Manis uh if you haven't
seen that game do check it out it is
quite a quite a brutal game first link
in the description below and you know
maybe after we check that one out return
to this one just to see what kind of a a
player we are dealing with also there's
a a meadow chilling in the background in
that video so that's also nice uh but
getting back to this one Gish needs to
do whatever he can to win this
tournament like I said even a shared
first will qualify him for the
candidates most likely we I mean it's
hard to say because you know stuff is
happening on a daily basis uh but he
should have excellent chances and the
clear first will definitely qualify him
so let's see what happens here uh sonon
has the white pieces and he opens with
E4 we have E5 from gkes Knight F3 Knight
to C6 and Bishop to C4 we have Bishop to
C5 allowing white to go for the
strongest move but sonon goes Pawn to D3
so choosing for the suboptimal line you
know hope it doesn't backfire later on
uh Knight to F6 and Knight B to D2 so
the Joko panimo variation is on the
board we have castles castles uh and
pawn to D6 we have Pawn to C3 uh many
many games in the database with this
exact setup we've had it on the channel
pretty much every every third video uh
H3 and now a pawn to H6 and what's
interesting about this position is that
Magnus Carlson actually played it three
times and he played against kakin he
played against Wesley so he played
against mvl and he lost all three games
so uh very weird Choice from Gish
obviously he found some improvements in
this line uh Rook to E1 with we have
Rook to E8 and now B4 is the most common
move here but we have Knight to F1 the
early uh Voyage of the Knight Bishop to
E3 is coming to one counter of course
black strong Bishop here and now Bishop
to E6 we have Bishop captures Rook
captures and now Pawn to B4 and uh for
example in the game that I mentioned mag
wle versus Magnus Magnus played Queen to
D7 but here we have Pawn to D5 right
away and queen to C2 and now again it's
a very well-known position Queen to D7
has been played here B E5 has been
played here D captures and E4 has been
played here many other moves also but we
have Knight to E7 by gkes and it is now
as of move 14 that we have a completely
new game and what Knight to E7 does uh
first of all it offers uh the E5 Pawn uh
well you have to capture on E5 and then
you just gobble up the E5 Pawn so is
that pawn free and why is Gish giving it
up well as uh sorry uh let me just
quickly uh the clocks weren't really
relevant up on up until this point but I
will will allow them now uh just because
um it could be relevant so give me just
a few seconds yeah there we go uh so
here uh you can see that um you know the
clock is uh hour and 14 minutes for for
suugo and an hour and 12 minutes for for
gcash but now upon offering this Pawn
suugo takes half an hour for his next
move and he decides to capture the pawn
uh maybe not the the best move
objectively maybe you should develop
with something like Rook B1 or Bishop D2
Bishop D3 but he does go for it he plays
e captur on D5 and you can see now that
his clock dropped to 52 minutes and okay
obviously Gish has something prepared
for this as he planned the the Knight A7
completely new move uh he plays Knight F
captures on D5 Knight captures on E5
grabbing the pawn and now just Knight to
G6 and also guer spent uh some time here
probably even more than you'd expect
from someone who prepared this line so
maybe he just didn't really prepare this
maybe he just just thought of it over
the board but who knows we have Pawn to
D4 now defending the Knight and Knight
captures we have D captures on E5 and
queen to A7 Gish now wants to win back
the pawn but also what he got from this
is the diagonal for his dark Square
bishop and you can't really oppose that
Bishop Bishop to E3 the Knight can just
capture it you can't play C4 because
Knight captures on B4 so for the moment
Gish controls this diagonal and he does
have pressure on E5 so here we have
Queen to E4 uh defending and also saying
if you capture on C3 I'm just going to
capture on B7 and that's going to be
very good for sonan so Kish plays C6 and
now we have Bishop to D2 so just
continuing development and while this is
all perfectly fine s now has 13 minutes
on the clock we have Rook to E8 Gish
triples up on the E file and queen to G4
uh and now Gish plays Pawn to F6 Pawn to
F5 is um also interesting but Pawn to F6
also works uh the thing is how do you
counter Pawn to F6 uh is there is there
a way to to do something about this well
uh the problem is you can't really
capture if you capture just Queen
captures and now you can't really deal
with all the pressure on the E file
because your F2 Pawn is hanging let's
not forget about our good friend Bishop
on A7 uh so here Pawn to C4 that's the
way to do it uh but now Gish prepared
Pawn to F5 so now how do you deal with
this the queen is attacked Queen to F3
was played uh also you could capture on
F5 but then just Rook to f8 and you
really have problems here so you have to
move the queen Queen to F3 was played
and now Knight captures on B4 we have
Queen to B3 now putting pressure on the
knight uh and also if the Knight moves
uh you will have some pressure on B7 but
just A5 defending the Knight and now
Knight to G3 going after the F5 pawn and
now Queen to H4 and this is where the
fun really happens how do you how do you
play this it's a it's a very tricky
position where of course if the Knight
moves Knight captures on F5 then Queen
captures on F2 with check and doesn't
matter where you go to you just pick up
the Knight so it would be a piece
blunder another thing uh let's say go
Rook eight to D1 which is the strongest
move and it often is in many positions
uh you you you have to allow Bishop
captures an F2 and then after King
captures Pawn to F4 and this is sort of
best for uh white but I mean uh how how
do you do something like this like King
to G1 now Queen captures or F captures
just looks very weird to allow this but
it is the way to go however C5 was
played in order to prevent Bishop
captures on F2 and also to create pin
here against the black king so you don't
have Rook captures on E5 but it involves
giving up the C5 pawn and now Bishop to
E3 so okay The Rook cannot capture on E5
you also counter the bishop on this long
diagonal but now gas just trades it
Bishop captures on E3 we have Rook
captures on E3 you can play F captures
because the Knight hangs so you have to
play Rook captures on E3 allow Pawn to
F4 and now you pin the pawn so F
captures on G3 cannot happen uh but now
we have Knight to D5
asking what do you play here with white
uh and the the answer is uh you you
don't play something weird like Queen
captures on B7 which is what happened in
the game you have to play Rook a to E1
you double up here and only then after
let's say queen to G5 not threatening to
win the Knight you bring the Knight back
and then something like B6 okay the pawn
is defended and black is still better
but maybe white can fight however after
Queen captures on B7 the game is
completely winning for gash and I'm sure
you guys have an idea why but just in
case feel free to pause the video and
win the game for gash while I give you a
couple of seconds uh and you can see
that he has 20 minutes on the clock
sonan only has two and a half minutes so
it's very hard to
defend so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on paying
attention to the previous line as I did
expose the threat and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show Queen
not that obviously Queen to G5 is the
move and now the Knight is hanging what
do you do Knight to F1 was played now
Rook to G6 threatening Queen captures on
G2 Checkmate and just no good way to
deal with this you have to advance the G
Pawn but now not captures uh Queen to F5
going after the Rook here so Rook a to
E1 doubling up but now as it was a
double Attack Just Queen captures on H3
and it looks like okay you have the pawn
the Knight maybe the queen comes in to
help maybe you can still defend not
really Queen B3 adding a Defender and
also pinning the Knight here uh but just
F captures on G3 we have Knight captures
and G3 and here
uh you could just play H5 H4 there's no
way for for the uh Pawn to move but
rukes uh shows us there's another way to
play this Rook to f8 and now look at
this horror his idea is Rook to F5 as
the Knight cannot move Rook to H five
the Knight again cannot move and queen
to H1 Checkmate as the Knight again
cannot move so how do you how do you
stop this uh Rook one to E3 was played
he offered um not really offered as the
Knight still cannot move so he doubles
up the Rooks for free also stop some
Rook to F3 ideas in the future uh but
now just Rook F5 like we mentioned and
now Queen to D1 he has to cover the H5
Square other otherwise Rook to H5 is
winning and now Knight captures an E3
Gish just takes the material in order to
defend gush had uh Salan had to do
something but okay Gish will of course
take the free material Rook captures an
E3 and now Rook back to f8 if this was
you know some game where you wanted to
score Beauty points you'd play Rook to
H5 uh but doesn't want to allow
something like Queen to F3 defends this
and now okay you could play something
like this and you're still you still
know you're winning but um maybe you
give white some unnecessary chances here
so he just goes back Rook to f8 and he
says you you have nothing to look for in
this game Queen to D3 was played putting
pressure on The Rook but now just Queen
back to E6 stopping the pass pawn
consolidating and that's all the isace
king to F1 was played but now just Rook
to G4 and he was in this position un
move 40 with one minute on the clock
that sonan suugo resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
you're down you're down too much
material and there's not much to look
for here you can't Advance the pawn you
can't trade anything there's nothing to
capture there's nothing to threaten your
A4 Pawn is hanging and there's just no
good way to do it if you if you offer a
trade of course you happily trade here
captures captures Queen F7 you have
constant pressure here there's no uh
there's no try here for white whatever
you play You're Just worse and uh once
once black stabilizes it's merely a
matter of advantage ing pawns there
there's no counterplay here for white uh
so that's why after work to G4 he
resigned and gkes takes the sole lead in
the tournament he overtakes Hari Krishna
and like we said if he wins Soul first
he will be leading the FID circuit and
he will qualify for the candidates
tournament via the the F circuit unless
Anish finds a tournament to play or you
know Wesley where where they can
overtake uh all of them in the FED
circuit it's not uh it's not
unimaginable as new tournaments are
appearing um you know every day and yeah
okay you still have the world rapid and
Blitz Championship which is part of the
fet circuit but you can't really count
on becoming World Rapid or Blitz
Champion uh I mean it it's fairly
unrealistic goal although it is possible
I mean anyone can do it uh so yeah
that's the game uh very nicely done by
gkas taking down two times world
champion and three times European
Champion sonan suugo with the black
pieces no less incredible stuff here I
would like to thank an anonymous person
Benjamin hyberger elf on a shelf Gregory
Novak and canet F for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions but mostly keeping uh you
know a close eye on what is happening
with the candidates tournament so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day